Just as a refresher,
let's recall the basic elements of computational photography.
But first, let's imagine what is our scenario.
We want to take a picture of a 3D scene, as demonstrated here, and
what we want to convert into is a picture.
So in essence, what we have done is we have taken the rays of light that
are illuminating the scene, and converted it into a two-dimensional picture.
Now recall that the main aspects of the computational photography started with
illuminating the scene, the optics that were used to then take the light
information and get it onto a sensor which was then converted into an image.
And then we can do various types of image processing on it.
That would be displayed into a picture like this.
As you may, may remember, our goal was to computationalize each and
every aspect of this pipeline.
Today of course, in this lesson, what I'm interested in having you
start thinking about how the digital information,
the sensor, can be actually used to generate a representation that we
can actually do various types of image processing on.
So then we can display an image.
So the three main aspects that we're interested in here is how
the digital information from the sensor is put on to generate an image that we
can do various types of processing on it to generate a picture.
We will discuss more aspects of how a sensor does generate this kind of
a signal in a later lecture.
Today the goal is for us to start thinking about how we can actually start
doing image processing and computer vision types of techniques on images.
So, the goal that we have in this lesson is to be able to
make an image a computable entity.
That is, we can run various, various types of computational processes on it, and
actually allow us to start thinking of what is a digital image, and
what's a representation of a digital image, to convert and create images and
pictures that we can use for processing.